so we're living in an age where the
worst seemed to be on a Perpetual
ascendance they become White House Press
Secretary the dumbest Among Us and the
best are crushed and we believe Simon
atiba is one of the best he's one of the
very few journalists in the White House
briefing room who asks real questions he
is the top reporter from Africa in
Washington and for that he's hated green
Jean-Pierre has been avoiding him for
months now simonativa has learned he's
being booted from the White House
correspondence Association which
controls access the White House
briefings kind of shocking news
summative is with Today News Africa he
joins us tonight Simon I'm sorry to hear
this news I'm shocked by it how can you
be thrown out of the White House
correspondence Association on what
grounds
okay thank you for having me doctor
thank you thank you for having me on the
the show
um and and thank you for releasing the
the videos of the January 6 that showed
that uh we didn't have the full story
and I I just want to thank you
personally for for that of course so the
White House correspondent Association
has decided that uh I'm not worth it I'm
not supposed to be a member of the
association the denied they refused to
renew my membership they are trying to
help the press secretary Kareem jump
here because when you do the right thing
when you ask the right question they try
to silence you to try to censor you and
the only thing they are doing to me
right now is trying to punish me for
trying to be a real journalist for
asking the question that the American
people really care about and it's
shameful it's a disgrace and the
president of the White House
correspondence Association Tamra kid who
worked for NPR a a publicly funded media
organization should be ashamed of
ourselves
absolutely ashamed of her stuff so you
NPR's correspondent its fake reporter is
colluding with the White House Press
Secretary to throw the one guy in the
room out to ask real questions that's
what you're saying
yes exactly when you do the right thing
when you don't send questions in advance
Karen jump here she's totally
incompetent she can't even answer basic
questions she lies a lot she's like
she's lied repeatedly about the
classified document about other things
when you ask those questions when you
press for the truth the silence you I
never believed that this could happen to
me in the United States in Africa when
we look up to the us we saw the beacon
of light the beacon of Excellence the
beginning of Free Speech but here I am
right in the White House in the most
powerful house in the world being
censored being punished by Tamra kid of
NPR the waca who are totally incompetent
and collect colluding with the White
House to punish someone who is doing the
right thing
it's unbelievable the state broadcaster
NPR is including with the state to shut
down free speech it's just I wonder if
NPR's media correspondent will cover the
story so I'm going to Tibet we are
blessed by your presence on the show
thank you and I'm sorry thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight